[Musique]
les sadristes ya des choix
il nous reste qu'à peine quatre semaines
pour finir de faire de vous des sondages
tiens en voilà un prêt à y aller
et toi conte breuil j'ai vu que tu
t'étais trouver un chien si ça se trouve
le sergent une mascotte pour notre
compagnie pour qu'on se démarque
ouais on va se démarquer à l'odeur est
mort on arrête eh bien je crois que tous
les hommes et les chiens de bonnes
volontés sont les bienvenues dans ce
combat au travail sans merci serge en
patois idiot je parlais à ton chien
alors nous deux on est censé faire
comment je sais
attention à brisbane
mais maintenant vous les américains vous
êtes la baguette au fil des posts à nous
pour marquer à tout instant
[Musique]
le chalet des tout premiers
j'aimerais avoir la moitié de son rap du
courage ça c'est pas du courage d'un
ciel et celui ci nous viendrait presque
corde est en guerre merci devrait
prendre exemple sur lui
[Musique]